وشكرا على الموضوع للموضوع نعم
في ظني انه في الشرق الاوسط هناك نوعين من
النظام الملكي نظام الملكي اللي تاسس بعد
مؤتمرستيفالي وانشاء الدوله الوطنيه 1648
اللي
ظهر في الدوله السعوديه الاولى وهو انشاء
دوله مملكه وخاصه بعد محمد بن سعود عبد
العزيز محمد انشا دوله اذا تاخذ خريطه
1814 ترى انه الدوله السعوديه الاولى هي
الوازنه مع الدوله القادريه
والعثمانيين وهي العاصمه الملكيه الاولى
للعالم العربي هذه الانظمه الملكيه التي
تنشا من بيئتها يعني محمد الامام محمد بن
سعود اتى من بيئته وتراكم تاريخي ثم انشا
نظام الملكيه وهذه النظام الملكي استمر
بدليل بعد سقوط الدرعيه عاد النظام الملكي
السعودي مره اخرى في الدوله السعوديه
الثانيه ثم عاد في الدوله السعوديه
الثالثه لانه هذا نظام ملكي اتى من بيئته
وهناك عقد اجتماعي و شرعيته وهذا يستمر
دائما بدليل دول الخليج يعني دول الخليج
في كل المراحل في الكويت استمر النظام
الملكي في الامارات هذا النموذج السعودي
يستمر دائما لانه ابنه
النظام الاخر الملكي كان نظاما مستوردا
مستعمرا
مفروضه بالقوه يعني الملكيه المصريه لم
تكن ملكيه مصريه فعليا هي ملكيه البانيه
تركيه وبالتالي سقطت ولن تعود من الصعب ان
تعود ايضا الملكيه العراقيه المالكيه
مستورده بريطانيا قررت اتخاذ
في سوريا كانت مؤقته لمده
1918 الى
المتوكليه في اليمن نفس الطريقه رفضه فهذا
النموذج لا ياتي من فئه